[Musique]
on va commencer à installer vous dans
votre fauteuil et bien gentiment sur ces
images filmées par la caméra de vidéo
surveillance on aperçoit une femme
rangée sa voiture avant de se rendre
compte que son petit cousin présent dans
la poussette se dirige dangereusement
vers une voie rapide
je n'ai même pas eu le temps de
réfléchir j'ai foncé par chance
renessman ancien sans-abris installé
chez sa sœur depuis trois mois est assis
sur un banc de la station-service il
sort juste d'un entretien d'embauche à
proximité quand il se transforme en
sauveur mais là tu cries encore plus
fort et ça persiste
[Musique]
paniquer la femme tente malgré tout de
réagir mais tomba nouveau c'est à ce
moment la queue ronesse mal intervient
alors j'ai directement crier je l'ai je
me sentais mal pour cette dame j'ai des
neveux et des nièces je ne pouvais pas
imaginer vivre une telle scène en fait
on s'est marcher dessus je me suis rendu
à cheville mais ça arrive parce qu'en
fait moi j'ai une descente de break
juste là derrière sauf qu'elle doit
reculer vite vite c'est les risques du
métier direction vers les supers crosses
batteur
autant j'ai dormi avec lui dans son lit
elle recommence
elle prétend que j'ai dormi avec elle
enfin dormir ça je veux bien mais elle
prétend que il se serait passé que j'ai
jamais dit ça j'ai dit que tu avais le
barreau
alors
dis donc tu sais très bien parce que
j'ai touché attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que c'est Laurent qu'est-ce que
c'est Élise Lucet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je rentre de vacances je vois
scandale Bruno Le Maire a écrit un livre
érotique très bien moi je m'apprêtais à
lire fougue américaine et bien pas du
tout c'est vraiment fugue américaine que
j'ai lu c'est un livre qui n'est pas du
tout érotique il y a deux passages
érotiques qui sont assez maladroits qui
sont assez une faute de goût je dirais
qui moi me touche assez parce qu'on
dirait vous savez nous expliquer je vais
vous expliquer je trouve que c'est le
premier de la classe qui a envie de se
jouer
exactement les scènes de sexe fond
ricaner en l'occurrence 7 du livre de
Bruno Le Maire est considéré comme
vulgaire et mal écrite elle me tournait
le dos elle se jetait sur le lit elle me
montrait le renflement brun de son anus
tu viens Oscar je suis dilaté comme
jamais
tu es jaloux comment il s'appelle déjà
Hugo
il est jaloux il est jaloux de toi j'ai
touché le kiki à papa avant toi
mais quoi il y a pas de mal c'est Tony
j'ai pas les mêmes j'ai pas les mêmes
atouts que Michel vous êtes ravissant
quand même mais attention
le premier
[Rires]
c'est connu dans le métier il y a
quelques jours les 10 ans du mariage
pour tous
le 23 avril c'était 2013 les gueules et
lesbiennes obtenez enfin le droit comme
nous les hétéros de se marier de
regretter puis de divorcer et c'est à
même un double anniversaire parce que
c'était aussi les dix ans du triple AVC
de Christine Boutin
alors on l'a perdu au moment où la loi
passe on a on a perdu
on a notre Laurent Ruquier qui va se
rajouter à cette enquête
vis sont des radis de vous avoir Laurent
vous a croisé dans les loges je sais
donc il a vu le costume d'un peu plus
près encore que nos enquêteurs il semble
avoir reconnu vos cuisses pardon
et puis alors ce petit jeune oui alors
voilà pardon je fais le tour mais Manu
dont j'ai vu aussi le spectacle qui est
une merveille et on se connait depuis
très longtemps c'est vrai et je l'ai
connu tout jeune ce petit gars-là et ton
spectacle est absolument formidable moi
je vous dis simplement ça fait très
longtemps que j'ai parlé comme ça
pendant 1h30 j'ai été
j'ai fait pipi
[Applaudissements]
content de revoir le chameau un
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut
c'est ce qu'il faut pour l'Eurovision
qui parle je suis sûr j'ai aussi eu
l'euro
parce que le problème c'est que gagner
c'est vous qui organisez l'année d'après
25 millions d'euros donc les chaînes
n'ont pas cet argent il y avait un cœur
il y avait un lien quand vous vous
teniez la main dans la main
dans la main
même
main dans la main
en tous les cas quand j'étais à France 2
j'avais ordre de perdre et à la RTBF
j'avais ordre de pervers ils avaient
gagné quelques années avant ils avaient
été obligé de licencier
2000 personnes à cause de ce que ça
avait écouté
de capitaine de police afin du peuple
qu'est-ce que ça fait de passer de ce
qui tire les flash-ball à ceux qui les
reçoivent
moi j'ai un problème c'est que j'arrive
pas à rire avec certaines choses
[Rires]
merci pour votre bienveillance j'ai
adoré faire cette blague alors votre
retour
en attendant les aventures de Martine
sont à l'aigrement détourner sur les
réseaux sociaux preuve que la jeune
fille continue d'inspirer malgré les
années
d'ici là bonne semaine à tous et surtout
n'oubliez pas de vous faire du bien
[Musique]